seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm I tast Sweet Victory
I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David valueing giv values
contagious this world entrepreneurs we
get no value to ha run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the one
let's see this here to see if I'm
getting the audio right or wrong Chris
just taught me how to use this apple new
iPad I'm used to using the old one but
today guys I have not done a
bodybuilding interview for probably I
can't even tell you I haven't done one
for probably 4 five years and there's a
reason for it uh this is a space I was
very interested in when I was younger I
got out of high school I wanted to be Mr
Olympia I went and did the whole thing
and I went to Mr Olympia I hung out with
these guys to see what the life was
going to be like and then you know hey
if you want to win Mr Olympia what's the
right height what do you got to be
what's this got to be this do I do this
do I do that and I finally one day I'm
like Mr Olympia is not for me I'm
leaving well maybe later on I'll do
something I wanted to buy Mr Olympia so
I had a meeting with them uh three
months before they announced Jake Wood
bought Mr Olympia and I wanted to make
an offer and said no we're never going
to be selling we don't have this we
don't have that then Jake would bu I
said I'm done with Mr Olympia I walked
away however I did a bunch of interviews
with a bunch of the guys and you're the
first one I'm doing since then because
you're
um a very
interesting uh profile of a bodybuilder
which doesn't make sense and let me
explain to you why okay here we go with
this number one this guy is uh Rob can
you play this clip for some of you that
maybe he's got himself covered so you
don't he's not showing his arms he's not
showing his body I just want you to see
this clip I can't play the music uh
because YouTube's not going to be happy
with us uh uh you know which clip I'm
talking about Rob that one right there
just watch this clip here this is this
is him at 2 years old we can't play the
music so this is you I'm sure you've
seen this very cute sick hat that's yeah
he's he's got sty very flexible look at
this guy here good looking younga 10
years old boom holy he's got
muscles and Swagger damn 18 years old is
that five plates tail too jeez yeah
you're rocking the bun dude and then you
come to 19 okay I can do something with
this body and then
20 then all of a sudden you go to 21
shoulders popping
out you're seeing a difference now waist
staying small look at that waist very
hard to keep it the weight is small
still haven't eaten one carb yeah
24 25 it'll come up and all of a sudden
show you where at this is when you start
winning 25 the beard shows up there it
is
26 and then boom five time Mr Olympia
classic
Champion um and and it's interesting
because you're you're the most followed
guy in bodybuilding outside of Arnold I
believe and Arnold obviously has had a
run rate for many years and you know
he's a governor actor he's the goat in
the bodybuilding space for doing a full
life everything that he's done together
but he got 22 million followers on
Instagram 5 million nearly 5 million on
Tik Tok nearly 4 million Subs on YouTube
and anybody I talk to from the
bodybuilding space you're loved and
you're liked a lot of people
are maybe loved admired but not liked
some are liked but they're not loved and
admired very few are loved and admired
and they stay humble and they're chill
and you and I were talking I was
inviting you to a party like hey man I'd
love to come but I got to go somewhere
because I'm handling something I'm like
okay cool you're just very straight up
about it and we talked about it I'm like
look at this guy freaking amazing guy
said let's have him on and then here we
are talking to the five-time Mr Olympia
Champion it's great to have you on the
podcast thank you sir it's an honor to
be here hell of an intro there I've
never seen that video so you've never
video Haven SE yeah so that's a video of
you man what you've done and where you
are today a lot of young guys look up to
you with um the way you handle yourself
how humble you are and you're a champion
and you openly talk about the challenges
and you're expecting a a child which is
ex exciting I saw the video you left
everybody hang in you know with the
twice with the clip you're about to tell
us and then boom and then second time
you tell us and then boom so I also like
the way you're creating your content so
let's go from the beginning I got a few
stories I want to go through here with
you I want to talk about a couple things
with health uh obesity some stats we got
here for you some of it's taking place
within kids we'll talk about some other
things having to do with bodybuilders
I'll show you some pictures of some guys
who have won in the past before I want
to get your thoughts on how you look at
different different bodybuilders on
their physiques different Champions
that's been in the game for a while and
then some of the stuff we'll talk about
the current state of bodybuilding the
current state of Mr Olympia and I'm sure
we'll talk about a bunch of other things
but before we get started for the
audience that doesn't know your
background how did you get into
bodybuilding was it a natural transition
into it where you want to be Mr Olympia
was it something like purely
accidental it was definitely a little
accidental when I was younger I love
playing sports I played way too many
sports to be good at any one sport that
was kind of my problem I was very
athletic and instead of falling into
putting in my training into being a
better football player basketball player
in the skill I fell in love with
training and alone and being in the gym
and wanting to be stronger cuz I was
just naturally very athletic so I spent
all my time in the gym rather than
practicing the skill of sports and
slowly you know people start to get
really good you know I started to get
beat out in all the sports and I just
started spending all my time in the gym
and then when I was 17 years old my
sister started dating a local
bodybuilder and they're actually now
married he's my brother-in-law oh wow
and he got me into understanding the
true depth of bodybuilding what it
really took the training the nutrition
recovery everything and he saw some
potential in me he's like hey I'd love
to coach you for a bodybuilding show if
you want and I was like hell yeah like
let's try it out how old are you at this
time that was when I was 17 oh wow but I
didn't compete until two years later got
it so I was still just training up and
then he coached me when I was 19 to do
my first show and the cool thing is he
actually coached me for eight years
after that and we won three Mr Olympia
titles together so from getting me to
the gym teaching me the ropes to three
Olympia titles so he got you so you guys
at three together so then is that when
Hy showed up is that that's when I
switch over to honey got it and how did
that transition happen with honey um
Supernatural you know Ian my
brother-in-law Ian he was competing in
the Olympia as well so imagine competing
for the Olympia having to prep yourself
be Peak weak dieting get yourself right
it seen in documentary that you created
the the video as well where he's also
jacked and he's like I'm excited because
I'm actually going to be on the stage
okay so that's your brother-in-law the
blond guy got it the blond guy yes yes
so it's pretty difficult to manage what
you're doing while also having the
pressure of a three time Olympia
champion and making sure I come in
perfectly so it was taking away from his
able to ability to compete and he felt
like he wasn't able to give me his all
as a coach so we started talking about
bringing in someone new so he came up
and he says I've taken you this far you
need somebody else to take you to the
next level was it that kind of a
conversation wow we we were definitely
on the same page but he was all for he
just wanted what interesting for him to
do that's not easy to do when somebody
says so what was the difference cuz Hy
for people that don't know if he can
pull up Hy how do you spell his last
name by the way it's o r a m b o d he's
Persian I should know how to spell his
last name we talk all the time this guy
is is a by the way the amount of people
he's worked with that he's helped Phil
has worked with him Phil speaks very
highly of him you got shopan you got
just recently um uh Mr Olympia Champion
as well a lot of people have worked with
him what is the biggest difference of
working with hany versus your
brother-in-law what did you notice
immediately I would probably say the the
experience of working with Champions you
know there's a level where you
understand the basics and all things in
life are like this you understand the
basics of fundamentals of everything you
can keep getting better at those and
then there's something that only
experience really gives you at the top
level a lot of the com combination of
the mindset how different everybody's
body is how differently you respond to
different stressors and different
simulations and all that stuff so when
there was a problem that would occur
maybe in like peak week you're about to
get on stage like for example this year
I woke up and I was holding on to a
bunch of water didn't look how I should
have I'd put on a bunch of weight
overnight randomly and you might Panic
be like we've got to be on stage in
three hours what do we do you don't know
what to do there's different
manipulations you can do with your body
but only so much you can do in a matter
of hours but he's been doing this with
Champions at a high level for 20 years
he has 24 Olympia titles under his belt
that he unbelievable crazy yeah so he
just understands how to problem solve
and doesn't overthink it doesn't stress
it and he can just pull it from his
experience is he is he driving you by
creating urgency or is he more bringing
you down down and keeping you calm and
we got this under control or is it a
combination of challenging you hey if
you really want this you got to do this
you know you got to push a little bit
more in this area this is an area does
he talk to you like an artist looking at
your body saying look at this angle here
look at this here if we work on this
what is that approach he has with you is
it more you feel calmer when he's around
or does he challenge you to go above and
beyond it's definitely a bit of both any
anyone who knows Hy knows he's a crazy
stress case sometimes and he's kind of
like the guy who carry all the stress so
you don't have to to but he's also the
guy who will never look at anything and
be satisfied you know for him to give
you a compliment I maybe got like two
over two years of working together
you're like the second he looks at you
and he'll just quietly he'll give a
little smile and a nod and you're like
oh that's a good thing nor normally
you won't even get like that little
spark in his eye it's just like all
right you could look the best feel the
best you've ever done and he's just like
all right we got to push more cardio cut
your carbs we got to start doing this
now like it's just what do we do to be
better he's always on that so so so
you're you're a five-time champion and
and for some people that don't know you
were born in ' 95 yeah you're February
2nd 95 you're 28 years old right it's
not like you're 38 years old or 39 years
old you know you're 28 years old which
means you can go as long as you want to
go I remember when I was in uh
YMCA and we're all starting to work out
there's a 16-year- old kid his name is
Arthur he had a brother named meou they
may see this and somebody may send it to
him Arthur had an insane and when I mean
insane I mean insane physique okay and
you could tell this guy's jeans are just
better than the rest of us he was 510
the right height that if you wanted to
make a run at it and then from there
you're kind of like but just his passion
wasn't there it's just kind of like yeah
I don't really care to be a mrst Olympia
or compete or any of this stuff at what
did you have to do because to be a
five-time champion in 28 you're a
good-looking guy you got a great
physique you're going to be attracted by
a lot of girls that want to be around
you you can be invited to all the
parties the drugs are going to be there
for you everything you want to to go to
the places that are going to be
distractions that crowd is going to be
attracted to a guy like you right how
did you at a young age manage to prevent
those Temptations of getting caught up
in drugs and all that other stuff to
become a five-time champion I mean I
definitely had a phase when I was
younger where I was a bit of a party
animal and that's where that when you
really look at some of my progressions
through the year you can see one year
that just flipped when I started to
compete at the Olympia and that was when
I really checked out of being I was in
college what year was how old were you
at the time it was around 2017 so 20177
6 years you're 22 Yeah was it a flip
like you're done is it it was was it
like a gradual guys I can't come to
Saturday not you used to go five days a
week now you're only going two days a
week and then one day a week it was a
gradual at first cuz I had qualified to
go the Olympia for my first time in 2017
and I started to pull away when I was in
prep obviously I'm in bed at like 8 to
9:00 p.m. while they're my college
roommates are partying downstairs and
I'm trying to sleep get up early for
cardio and then that was only a 12we
prep and then I'd come second that year
and that my first ever Olympia came
second place and that when I came home
and I was like like I can make
something of this like this is like I
can do this if I go if I'm doing like
60% of the year I'm going all in the
other half I'm kind of parting too much
if I go 100% in and I give everything
right now and I take out everything else
I know I can do this because the
one thing about bodybuilders man you
know look if you want to find out who
has the drugs who has the hookups to the
club who has the hookups to girls to
anything go talk to guys that work out a
gym no joke guys at sales managers okay
at B at 24hour at La Fin at any of these
gyms Powerhouse in La any of these place
they typically know every club promoter
every party guy every they know it all
so if you party with bodybuilders my
experience they were crazy I was going
to say this from your own experience
yeah they were crazy party guys I I
worked at B for almost a year so to me
it's like we know everybody and you
you you got access to you had the
Ecstasy guy you had the the cocaine guy
you had the this guy you had the
steroids guy you had the you know weed
guy with the best quality you had
everything you wanted you had access
within the gym so it's kind of hard to
you know get away from it and even when
you sometimes talk to you know some of
the guys who are known for having the
best physiques you know the the story is
always well that guy parted above and
beyond and he had a great physique and
he could have been a bigger Champion
it's not easy to say no to though
because it's right in front of you Chris
so your your your sister Melissa ifbb
Pro right so and obviously you you are
who you are is your is anybody else in
your family like were your mom and dad
like was your dad jacked was your like
do you have an uncle is it in the
bloodline it's def definitely have some
good genetics I can't deny that my dad
didn't compete or anything but there's
one picture I always go back to where he
was uh he was in high school and he did
he was a gymnast and he's at the bottom
of one of those pyramids they would
build and he's just down there hands on
the ground just triceps popping out of
oh really just Jack I like Dad you were
jacked in high school and he just
laughed so Melissa's excuse me Melissa's
husband is the guy that trained you
before Han yeah how did you guys meet
through her or did I was still in high
school she's 5 years older than me got
so he was like 22 at the time I was in
high school they started dating and
they've been together for like 12 years
now or whatever and he just started he
was competing at the time and started
teaching me the ropes and Coach me a few
years later that's sick Bro can you zoom
out a little bit so we can see the
comparison between the brother brother
uh
yeah if you can just click on that
anyone who like knows me and my sister
seen us train seen us compete my sister
had the better genetics of the two of us
oh yeah seriously yeah she has the
better genetics than the two of you but
like I must IM like what is Thanksgiving
like like you're going over to get like
some stuffing and they're like yeah
you're tricep dude like I don't is
everybody just judging
everybody it's definitely funny cuz
people meet me and they'd be like oh
you're a big dude blah blah I never felt
like I was a big dude cuz every dinner I
had at family dinner I was the smallest
second smallest guy or second biggest
guy at the table my brother-in-law is
always like 50 lbs heavier than me so
like I never felt like I was that big I
was never that strong he was always
stronger than me just Jack that yeah
kept me humble yeah I know exactly
that's cool that's cool so uh let's talk
bodybuilding so Mr Olympia today um I'm
having this conversation you know my
ideas of what I would do if I was
running a Olympia and I remember I did
this one instagram live bunch of guys
were on Phil Heath was on Kai green all
these guys get on and I said want to put
a million dollar prize for my own
contest I want to run and uh if if if
I'm not running Mr Olympia I'm going to
put a million bucks for first place I'm
going to run my own open but I'm going
to do on the same weekend as Mr Olympia
here's what I'm going to do not like I
was trying to piss anybody off but I
just chose a I thought it was
appropriate to do the same weekend you
know and see what's going to happen I
was willing to go to 2 million even a
bigger number but I wanted first place
to get a million dooll check when you
win however the direction I wanted to go
is using data to prove what was the
hardest thing to do that would earn the
respect of somebody winning and to me
the hardest thing to do with data today
is a small waist a nice symmetrical back
nice shoulders okay legs you know Boom
the movie The when you see these Hulk
like not Hulk like more Reeves type of
style physique or Frank Zayn type of
phys
it's also healthier you can also manage
expectations with the younger kids that
look up and say I want to be like that
guy because it's different when you're
looking nasal sombat you're like I
want to be like that guy dude that guy
died very early because he was taking
all the stuff that you you look at Greg
Kovac this guy's got 26 you ever seen a
picture with GRE kovak standing next to
Jay
Cutler have you ever seen can you pull
up this picture I sent you I thought it
was a joke I thought I thought this was
a joke well they probably did a little
bit of Photoshop with this but Greg
Kovac was known for Incline pressing
seven plates jeez incline pressing seven
plates his arms were known for being 26
and a half inches I met this guy 20s
something years ago you're looking at
him it it doesn't look real that doesn't
that looks like they photo like his
tricep is bigger than his head just type
in GRE Kovac in just type in GRE Kovac
anywhere else type in GRE Kovac and just
go to images and you'll see what this
look like um yeah just go over there or
maybe go some of the other pictures
shoulder that his his Del it just
doesn't make any sense when you would
see his you know body his arms put
biceps Greg kovak biceps if you just put
that up there GRE kak's biceps and go to
some of these pictures 26 and 1 12 inch
arms 26inch Arms This guy's got so the
younger kids they're coming up they're
like dude I want to have great kobc type
of physique my idea was is to flip it
mhm so if I ever own Mr Olympia the open
right now the top price is what $400,000
400 right okay and uh the winner this
year seems like the nicest guy who won
yeah great guy messaged him
congratulations God bless very much
about God you Family Guy good guy To Be
A Champion but I would flip it I would
make the prize
for the classic the bigger one and I
would lower the open one of course
that's going to piss a lot of people off
and that's why they're not going to want
me have it as the owner because that's a
different approach to take but why would
I do that when you sit there and you
look at the amount of people having
health issues with bodybuilding they're
not managing expectations properly do
you think the current format the way
they have where for you when you win
most people don't know when you win it's
only $50,000 what's $50,000 nothing now
obviously you don't rely on the $50,000
you make millions on top of Millions on
sponsorship and I heard your first
sponsorship was 2200 bucks a month when
you first got it you're like I can't
even believe I'm getting 20 richest I've
ever felt richest you ever you took your
friends out to the bar you're like hey
drinks on me what do you think about the
current format of Mr Olympia and I I
when I listen to you you sound very
diplomatic and and I don't know if
you've been trained on how to talk you
know how to give the Diplomatic answers
you're very careful on the words you
choose I watch you and uh maybe you're
going to give the Diplomatic answer
right now but if you were uh if if you
and I were able to get in and let's just
say we're running Mr Olympia we own it
you're running it okay you have the
opportunity to make a few changes
because you're thinking about the youth
you're thinking about the future you're
thinking about the brand you've given
your life to this you've got five
championships what would you do to
improve the brand it's funny because I
told my wife forc Coming I like your
style of everything because I know you
call everybody out for giving Pol
political answers I'm like if I give a
political answer he's going to call me
out not let me give so start with that
um no and the way you're think about it
and talking about data and the
progression of it I think the way
they're looking at it and I'm not going
to be super political is very short term
they're thinking
people are excited to come buy tickets
to watch open bodybuilders because it's
crazier to see but people don't want to
become that so it's a short-term goal
the older people want to come and they
want to watch it and to this year they
may sell more tickets but if you start
changing the prize money and
incentivizing more people to go into
classic physique and that grows more
that's more of a long-term play where
more people are going to be driven to
start when they're young to chase that
classic physique more people are going
to be following over years and years and
10 years down the road people may look
at bodybuilding as something fun but
they all want to watch classic and now
there's a lot more excitement around a
lot more competitiveness because there's
a lot more money to it so it's kind of a
longer term game and I know the way you
operate in business of course you
wouldn't have gotten where you are if
you weren't thinking long term so I
would agree I would probably put more
emphasis on classic physique I would
definitely be upping the prize money and
I've even thought when I'm whenever I'm
done with this and I choose to retire
retire I want to find some way to
incentivize that more obviously like you
said I found a good way to start my own
businesses and create my own net worth
out side of competing so I'm lucky in
that aspect but I want to help other
people who don't have that opportunity
but who want to compete be more so I
want to encourage more people whether it
be more sponsorship opportunities or
business opportunities for whoever the
classic physique winnner is plus po more
prize money more shows around the the
globe that incentivize it more just
different aspects something I've
definitely thought about yeah I I love
that especially you know coming from
somebody uh like you because when you
when you look at this you're wondering
this is what I would do if I uh uh
surveyed everybody who bought a ticket
this year I would ask I would put a list
of all the top competitors who are there
and I would do a survey from everybody
that bought a ticket and I would ask who
is the number one person you're coming
to see if I'm running Mr Olympia because
that's the data I want y so then if I
all of a sudden notice the guy that's
got 22 million Instagram
followers uh 23% are coming to see you
second place 17 % are coming to see
Derek or Hadi or whoever else it is
right 133% are if I see those
numbers why is the
23% that's coming to see you getting
paid 50 and the 177% is getting to 400
because that's a real valid question to
be asking that data is going to reveal
who's selling the tickets and I don't
know if they do that data or Not by the
way Mr Olympia if you're watching and if
you guys are involved in Mr
you guys to ask this you're Olympia go
up you know who your are go and say Can
We R numbers and FYI for the rest of you
that are more from uh support of what
direction he's going to and you actually
want this industry to get healthier and
you would like this thing to be on
National Television not the way it's
going right now it's not going to be if
you want it to be on National Television
which is when you get the big checks the
big money the big dollars and prices can
get higher that is a very valid question
to ask because when the last time Mr
Olympia was televised long time ago no
idea why is that it's because of the
steroids and the issues and the
challenges and the health so everybody
that wants to do they're like well eight
people died this last year this many
bodybuilders died because they're using
TR or whatever else they're using and
that negative connotation comes with it
but if you all of a sudden say no we
want to highlight this kind of a
physique it can change the game do you
think it would change it though if
because it's still well known that
everybody uses steroids no question
about it yeah so does it matter how much
they're using or the fact they're using
it at all I don't care if you use
steroids matter of I know you don't but
the average person on national
television but I also think like I I
think we used to care who you smoke weed
like when you and I were I keep saying
when you and I you're 28 I'm 45 I forget
the age difference 17 years I talk to
you like you know uh you're a champion
you know career you've had 20 years
you've not had a 20y year career you
only got like a sixy year career it's
crazy your career is only six years and
you won five out of six times no but
there was a time when I was in high
school you would see a guy with a tattoo
you're like that guy must be a gangster
or he's been in jail no joke I'm 45 at
13 years old that's the first thing I
thought about like damn that guy's got a
tattoo he probably killed somebody it's
probably yes or no Rob are you like not
kind of thinking about it that wayling
over there you're kind of like school
that guy skip school he's probably a
troublemaker a knife in his waist today
if you see a guy without a tattoo you
actually ask that guy's probably got
some issues he's got some insecurities
he's probably
this right we're like this guy without
the tattoo has the issue back in the
days the guy with the tattoo had issue
30 years ago if you smoke weed like look
at that guy man he smokes weed he's a
drug addict he's doing this he's doing
that Joe Rogan comes out and says stop
it knock it off you know you guys more
people die from smoking cigarettes or
more people die from alcohol than do
they do about this let's get under
control I think the education for peeds
steroids peptides GH they need to look
at that and especially now that we're
looking at the testosterone levels for
the Youth being as low as it is what
caused this why do we have this why are
we not looking at this why are we
looking at maybe boys are a little bit
more soft and pansies is there a
correlation to the testosterone levels
that we have why are we not
investigating this is the world a better
place with softer men in a country like
this America I don't know about that so
what are we doing to protect the future
security of the country you need some
strong men with strong personalities and
masculinity high testosterone that are
willing to fight that willing to put
their lives on the line that's the so
who's selling it that way I don't know
um but for me when I think about the
sport somebody needs to be able to
educate the pop I was kind of excited
when Rock was going to buy Mr Olympia
you remember when that conversation was
I'm like dude I hope this guy buys it
because if him and Danny bought it guess
what like do you know what they would do
to like think about if rock change yeah
what changes you think would have taken
place if Rock and Danny bought it I
think a lot of stuff like you were
saying would be more long-term Vision
they'd be running more data switching
over to make it more mainstream they're
all about making something more
mainstream to get it on National
Television to get real sponsorships part
of it to get some real money he was
already talking about bringing in Ford
and voson as sponsorships which have a
lot more money than any of the small
businesses not small but mediumsized
businesses that are in there now so it
would just start growing like that yeah
and look I don't have anything about
Jake Wood I've never spent time with the
guy I know he is a guy that actually
loves bodybuilding itself and he was a
guy that apparently was very much
interested in the female bodybuilding
side that's where he was very involved
in and he picked up the brand but it's a
difference between having somebody like
a weer who loves the game and is a
marketer versus somebody that just loves
the game if you bring a guy that loves
the game and as a marketer it's going to
be different story so I don't know if
you'll answer this but if you don't
totally get it just
guesstimation and maybe because you're
in the world and you hear some people
say about this do you think more people
come to watch Mr Olympia when he out
there POS and the audience is there what
is the size difference of the audience
of yours versus the open is it
traumatically difference where the open
is packed and you guys are not or about
the same I can't judge that because
we're on right after each other so like
got it in the morning there's two stages
and then at night we're on the same
stage and it's the same crowd got it so
there's not a way to judge that so okay
what what ways could Mr Olympia do due
diligence to see why the fans are coming
to watch the show is there ways to find
out like maybe you would know I mean the
way you said about taking data and doing
a survey would definitely help but I
also think that right now my following
and a lot of the people who are
transitioning over to really liking the
more classic physique look and a more
attainable look are a little bit younger
may have less money to travel to Vegas
and buy a ticket but if you start
building that up in five years now these
guys are the people and the the head
positions at companies with real careers
who can afford it so again it's a more
long-term play to start building
something that those that next
generation will want to come and
purchase tickets for so it's hard to say
cuz if you did your survey right now
let's say you said I'm 23% and then the
winner of Olympia is 10% but what if the
next guy is 9% and that's also in the
open the open and then the next guy is
like another 9% and he's also open and
the combination like 38% maybe I'm 23
but the combination of the top five guys
in the open is a little bit higher right
now but by the way you know what I would
do if they did that then at least that's
going to prove that they're doing the
right thing but let's just say it's 2 to
one yeah but the price is 8 to to one
that doesn't make any sense to me mhm if
it is 2 to1 well then the classic needs
to go to $200,000 and the open can stay
at $400,000 50,000 dude if I was your
manager they would hate me because I'd
be calling them every single freaking
week saying dude this guy stepping away
cuz he's going to go do something else
he's already making a ton of money
he's about to be a father Family Guy
he's not going to waste his time with
this he wants to do something bigger and
he's only 28 you guys better change the
price or else I would be the most hated
guy when they would get these calls but
I'm not in that business they it would
be Lu yeah
no just laugh it would be different kind
of phone calls than yet so um on this
topic I want to uh uh kind of go through
some of the pictures here bodybuilding
pictures every time I've had to guest I
show to I think the first time I did it
with Doran Yates Yates started I don't
know if you've seen that one when Yates
is you know looking at the pictures and
then I did it with we had flex and
Ronnie and uh uh uh uh Brandon Kurt we
had a bunch of these guys sha Ray showed
up even I think we did sha Ray and did
Dexter Dexter to me one of the sickest
physiques the the way his pictures would
come up Rob can you pull up some of
these pictures I just want to get your
thoughts on some of these pictures here
when you think about uh Mr Olympia uh uh
competitors and we can start off with
him when you think about Shawn Ray's
physique that you know historically
everyone's always called his physique
one of the greatest physiques of all
time he never won but I think he's been
in a top three more than anybody else
there's a statistic about how many times
he was in the top three more than anyone
else what do you think when you think of
Shawn Ray's
physique I think he had a beautiful
classic physique for sure I think I
don't even think he'd make the weight
limit for classic anymore honestly cuz
he was a little little bit shorter but
great lines great physique he had that
small waist and he had that like very
symmetrical physique you know a lot of
like my physique I have to pose to make
it look a little more symmetrical and
give the illusion he could stand
straight on the more straight on you can
hit every pose no angles or anything
shows you that you're not hiding
anything and it's just perfect you have
you know everything bubbling rounding
how do you think he would do in today's
classic you think he would he I don't
know if he'd make weight you don't know
if he'd make weight I think he'd be a
little heavier yeah I mean he looks a
lot bigger
than a lot of the guys you see right now
in classic so it's hard to say I don't
know what he weighed or how T what would
be the weight what's the weight you have
to hit it's a ratio of your height to
weight so I'm not sure exactly how tall
he is but for me at 6'1 it's 240 lbs he
would make it can you pull up a sha Ray
competition height weight I like that
the fact that there's a ratio of high to
weight I actually love that mm that's
very interesting that they so
56 contest he was 205 56 205 W 215 I
think 215 is definitely way over but I
think 56 would maybe he'd have to be 185
to 190 if I correct so if he's 56 he
would need to be 19 185 190 to compete I
think i' been quote me on this even even
if he gets to a weight like that do you
think he how how do you think he would
do in a classic today he'd be right up
there for sure he'd be right up there
okay so let's go to the next one after
Sean if you got whoever you want to go
to next who's this Kevin lron one of my
favorite physiques of all time when you
when you look at Kevin Leon go to the
picture to the left right there second
row first picture right there you see
this just click on it just let's go to
it and see look at this guy ridiculous
oh it's a video okay go back to whatever
it was on on the you have to go through
yeah there you go when you see Kevin's
physique what do you think about with
Kevin's
physique again I mean all these guys
from this era were the guys who didn't
win the Olympia in this era were just
wrong time you know they were around
some a lot of great people I think a lot
of these guys if you spread them over
time would have won Mr Olympia in their
own way but they were all against some
crazy competitors and you know he had a
great physique and it's hard to compare
a lot of these pictures cuz back then
there was a little bit of a different
look there were some I mean in this era
they were still just at lean cameras
were a little different you know
sometimes you watch the old videos that
are a little grainy and it makes them
look more grainy you know it's hard to
compare now the 4K cameras and
everything it's a lot different but he
was one of the guys who looked amazing
and this was I think Peak open size him
right here like this when his his era
around now if like open had stopped
around that cap rather than keep pushing
those limits so this was the peak of the
bodybuilding open era for Mr Olympia
yeah and it's difficult because someone
like Ronnie Coleman came around and he
could hold 300 lb and still look
aesthetic cuz he was a he's a one of one
you know got it keep going go to go to
the next one Rob uh uh uh Sergio are
these some of the guys that maybe you
know when you see a Sergio his son is
now competing as well yep and he's got a
great physique as well what what do you
think about Sergio's physique I mean
also a great physique I think this was
back in the era when they were a little
bit less dry and a little bit less lean
which I know a lot of people also liked
a little bit healthier as well but
everything progresses every sport you
see continuously imp progresses so it's
hard to say that anyone would still
appreciate looking at someone who's not
quite as lean but amazing physique he
had one of the smallest waste to arm
ratios that anyone's ever had one of the
smallest waste to arm ratios wow he had
yeah I mean but just look at his eyes he
looks like a king he looks like listen I
belong up here go to the next one
whoever we have next um hottie we have
obviously there's better pictures of
hotti uh uh he's another guy that's
loved as well you know you talk to guys
about hotti they have nothing but good
things to say about him
uh uh what do you think about hottie I
think hot's won it how many times now
two or three times um the open I think
he only won it once did he he won it
last year and then Derek beat him this
year oh that's right because uh uh yes
you're right he only won it once yeah he
only won it once because he wanted
before as the most uh uh fan people's
champion no I love hotti and what I love
about him is he trains like an absolute
animal and this is why a lot of people
love him he's coached by Hy and I went
down to Texas at about 3 weeks out last
year and we were training together and
he he doesn't speak English he speaks
farsy and he's also kind of deaf so he
just kind of like he's very non-verbal
communication and he's like makes fun of
me teasing cing jokes and then it's like
time to do a set he's just like serious
he puts two more plates on and H's like
you don't need to do that heavy he's
like just shaks his head puts another
plate on and just go fall to the wall
just an animal in the gym so so has
hottie forced you to learn how to speak
farsy or not yet like your fary isn't
that good yet okay I thought maybe they
taught they taught me a few things when
I was down there but I for I can't say
that on there that's for sure yeah
there's typically one that they say that
has two letter KS in it but they know
what I'm talking about go go to the next
one I'm not going to say this is to me
this is what you think about this
physique like this is yeah I mean you're
going to keep pulling up I'm assuming
some of the greatest of all time and the
reason we're looking at their pictures
is because they were the best of all
time yeah Ser sural brains just like
there was something about Serge's
physique when you look at this like look
at like Yeah from ERS to chest to like
that do his waist yeah that's ridiculous
when they have that waist that looks
like it's like pinched like but that's
what you got that's when I when I look
at the physique of I put you guys in the
same Community because that's the body
right that's like the Godlike body you
want to recognize where you know it just
it looks it almost the the body you look
at that you appreciate it's almost
something you're never going to achieve
it has to be the word unbelievable right
it's not like believable mhm and some of
it has to be not duplicatable because
bodybuilding is not about being
duplicated it's about having great genes
yeah like somebody can do all the
steroids in the world dude you're never
going to look like that n this is not
something that you're going to have the
genes Factor comes with it as well keep
going Rob which is funny because they
call Classic physique sometimes more
attainable when realistically it's kind
of like the more genetic freaks out
there who just have the look you can't
work they call Classic more attainable
yeah it's you know 300 lb versus 220 lb
it's just the only thing I would say
with classic physique to me is
it's it's just going to get the Right
audience wanting to come in and see it
more and then you you can have the other
side for the biggest freak that if
somebody wants to have that but you know
even Flex you know this is they call
this one of the greatest pictures of
bodybuilder ever taken maybe if not the
greatest picture this is uh uh it just
doesn't make any sense when you look at
this picture with this guy his body he
used to do training with Mike matarazo
on
uh ESPN have you had any interaction
with flex have you guys I have yeah he
still comes around the shows a lot we'
I've spoken to him yeah a good guy and
I've definitely one of the physiques
that I looked at and I was like this is
this is it who are your top five
physiques like who do you think about
when you're like your top five do you
have a list um I I don't have a concrete
list but when I was younger I really
like Barry deay Barry deay yeah he was
just you know an All-American like
good-looking dude who had the a classic
physique es style I would say in terms
of like unattainable things Flex wheeler
was one of my favorite for sure he had a
twisting back double bicep on his knees
that's one of the craziest pictures I've
ever seen But Barry deay was a guy that
I really like physique of who else
anybody else that's a random name is
that's a random name I like Bob Paris
the way he posed yeah you know he was a
little bit smaller guy but really good
look too very like
aesthetic yeah Bob paris's physique was
I some inspiration from his posing
routines and stuff too were you a
gaspari guy or you know I wasn't like a
huge fan but I definitely respected it I
liked it yeah who else who else would
you put on that list the these are
interesting names you're
given Harris the
mayia I mean if you ask me the greatest
of all time I'd still say Ronnie Coleman
you put Ronnie as the go I think so yeah
not that that's where I would ever want
to see
the that look at dude his Vein on his
arm is bigger than my leg and there was
there was a point where before he was at
the beginning of his career of his Reign
the first like one to two where I think
he looked his best before he put on an
extra like 20 30 lbs or whatever when he
placed 16th right is that kind of what
you're saying or when he won no when he
won still and like the year before he
won just like at the beginning of his
Reign so what year would that be that's
a good question put Ronnie Coleman first
Mr Olympia put Ronnie colan first Mr
Olympia first Mr Olympia go go to the
picture to the right of
that is that the one no he was on the
left he's
younger yeah look at that he's young as
hell look at his b dude his biceps look
fake well this guy when he placed 16th
he was my favorite physique I would look
at when I would buy muscle magazine and
flex ridiculous but when he plays 16
you're like this guy looks insane his
biceps would build on top of each other
and had the layers on top of each other
there's something too that like I always
see the bodybuilding Community just
loves and respects about someone who's
no just loves to train no drama
no gossip just like in the gym kicking
ass leaves and does their own thing
stays in their own lane there's always
people who come into the world of
bodybuilding and people just love those
people cuz a guy like him you're guy
like him yeah not just a happy goodlucky
dude who just hard as in the gym
people just love it I and I remember
when I interviewed him I said Ronnie
have you ever gone to a fight in your
life never let say you ever had a fist
fight never you've never had a fist
fight never I mean if you look at the
guy you're not going to want to fight
him and then I said you ever punched
somebody in the face I've never punched
anybody I said not even as a cop never
he says well I did P he start really
classic story he says yeah it's a cop
yeah baby but not so click on that one
right there WRA to the right that shows
all the years well no what you just had
right there yeah click on the bigger one
see if it does is it a video or so let's
see this one here this is kind of
transition from 98 2000 look at 01
wow look at that 01 picture Vinnie geez
dude yeah so you put him at the top bro
can do do you have any of the pictures
of uh Chris and and
Arnold right next to each other this is
the main one that everybody
Compares look at those physiques go to
the next one
Rob look at look at the look at the
stomach and the waist of Chris that that
just keep
going keep going and Chris that's just a
20 that's 24 hours you just everything
you eat everything everything has to be
methodical you can't even slip up at all
yeah I mean every single year I've
competed it's gotten more and more
locked in and you see you can see keep
seeing results you know it's no joke
this year especially cuz I have a lot
more going on now with the businesses
and travel and just life I started to
realize I was kind of overex spending
myself on too many Avenues and you know
if you want to be the top 1% of anything
you can't be the 1% in the next thing
next to it it's got to be one so this
year at like 10 weeks out i' had been
traveling too much I was a little too
stressed my body wasn't feeling too hot
I was in Canada and I wasn't sleeping I
was overthinking had too much stuff on
my mind and it was just my body was in a
high state of stressed and I tore my lat
I lost a bunch of weight all this
was going on and I came home and I was
like you're Mr Olympia like you can't do
this by being a business owner and doing
travel and all this you have to
just be Mr Olympia right now and I shut
everything el else out I told my partner
I'm you got to take over the business
and everything cuz I got to do this and
I just everything was sleep at 9:00 at
the same day wake up do cardio at the
same time eat nap train at the same time
everything was just perfectly regimented
for the entire prep Chris so and and um
this is when you went from 262 to 250
lost 12 lbs and yeah it's a wild thing
when happens in that world because
psychologically you're like wait a
minute what is this all about it's a
tough moment you're going through by
yourself and it's not like you're
playing basketball or football that you
have a teammate to rely on to come
through that day CU you're off no you
are your teammate you you are the guy
that everybody's looking at the pressure
is a different pressure go ahead man
well I just realized we I just realized
that we look like like hit men for the
mafia cuz we're both wearing black I
just that's that's how we make our money
that's how we it's just we don't tell
people so so uh seeing seeing what like
a lot of these ex Mr Olympia like
healthwise have to deal with after like
Ronnie Coleman's back like I feel I know
cuz I followed his whole career I felt
really bad cuz you know I saw him like
in a wheelchair and his back was messed
up to Arnold and his heart and all you
know and a bunch of other athletes but
does that scare you at all all the all
the strain that you're putting on your
body now I know cuz you spoke about this
before on podcast that you have an
autoimmune disease with your kidneys
correct and um now that you have that's
one question and then now I mean you
have a we just mentioned that you have a
kid congratulations coming do you know
if it's a boy or a girl yet I do but my
wife allow when when I going to say but
and like is
it is it worth it Chris cuz I don't know
how many more you want to keep going for
you know it's it's stressful you know
it's it's tolling on your body you know
what the future if you keep going holds
you is it still worth it because I mean
right now you could comfortably stop
with your businesses with your name
you're you're crushing it and and I'm
and good for you do is it worth it that
now you could leave comfortable or or
are you going to just keep going because
that's your dream that's your vision and
that's what you want to do I mean it's
definitely a consistent question I ask
myself every year and I've been very
verble that I take it one year at a time
you know there's going to be a moment
where I don't want to and when you were
asking me initially what was that
initial like flip where I started to go
all in on bodybuilding and initially it
was 2017 when I came second Olympia but
then it was 2018 when I got sick and I
found out I have an automine disease and
I was in the hospital for like a week in
the middle of prep and I came out of
that and I didn't know if I'd be able to
compete again I didn't know if it would
be my last year competing I didn't know
what was going to happen and that's when
like I really was like like my
health could be an issue here and
luckily with unrelated to bodybuilding
is something that I had had prior to me
what I was born with it had hit me when
I was young and I didn't know what it
was but coming out of that I was like
like I could have lost it all right
now this is serious not only do am I
grateful that I still have the
opportunity to do this and I'm on borrow
time so I better give it my all but I
better be a lot more cautious of my
health so I started to do a lot more
blood work a lot more check-ins with my
doctors a lot more started reduc the
amount of drugs I would take cuz I knew
I could push my my my work harder rather
than just drugs focus on what I ate my
inflammation all these little things and
it's something I focused on and it's
also something where I knew I wouldn't
have a 10 15 year career as much as I
would love to keep going because I know
I could keep getting better and do this
for 10 olympias or so it's not my dream
you know it's not your dream to have 10
or plus no I've always told people it
won't be forever I still don't know how
many it's going to be right now I'm like
I've been getting healthier over the
years not getting worse so that's a huge
sign for me that I'm still going in the
right direction my physique is still
getting better I know I still have more
in me so I still take time off to the
Olympia I do my blood work I do my
check-in and I just kind of check in
with myself see how motivated I am to
keep pushing and how my health is doing
and then I make my decision am I going
to do another one why why why do why
keep doing it though because the the the
the more you do it are you getting more
sponsorship money and are you seeing
money coming from elsewhere increasing
like you know what I'm saying like it
you know is there correlation between
five Mr olympias and you know we made
$16.2 million the last 12 months and on
the fourth one we were at 12.3 and on
the third one we were at 6.7 and on the
second one we were at 2.1 and on the
first one we were at
$380,000 is there a correlation with you
more winning and more income and revenue
coming in or not yet I think in the
first four 3 to four there definitely
was and whether or not that was also
just time you know increasing at the
same time time but now we actually just
had this question asked to us the other
day if we thought that me winning the
Olympia has a big spike on the business
and our answer was no you know we've
established a business to be bigger than
myself now which was always the goal and
I don't think it is anymore and I
obviously don't compete for the $50,000
check theend of the year it's all and
it's and the reason I've never really
pushed into caring about that check is
because it's never why I've done it and
even if it was $400,000 I don't want
$400,000 you know my goals monetarily
are bigger than that my businesses are
always wanted to be bigger than that
I've never competed for that you know
when I compete it's it's for the Legacy
that I can build that I'm proud of it's
for the challenges that I know you know
when you push yourself through something
very difficult that's how you learn
about your true self you undercover new
levels that you can reach new parts of
yourself you didn't know about and then
when I'm at shows and I have moments of
you know after my speech that I can give
talking about hardships I've gone
through when people can relate to me
talking about the stressful moment of me
losing a bunch of weight tearing my LP
wanting to quit all these things and not
quitting I have kids from 12 years old
up to 30s or 40s coming up to me and
these kids could write me a letter and
they'll do something very personal like
this is for Christopher not seum cuz
they know I don't like seum is not me
I'm Christopher you know I've always
stayed true to myself and they'll be
crying tell me about how I've like
helped them and how my journey and my
stories motivate them and that was never
my intention but just by going through
this I know I'm helping these people
push themselves and try and create
better versions of themselves as well so
while it's increasing me to be a better
person making people around me a better
person that's really what drives me
consistently to keep doing this and what
I love so much about bodybuilding and
you know the journey and the suffering
that you go through to excel yourself as
a man so much more than a bodybuilder
that's really what drives me now and
like I said I think I have like I could
probably win 10 olympias if I wanted to
but I'm going to pull earlier than that
because of these reasons what's worth it
what's the bigger regret I'm going to
have in the future having 10 olympias or
being sick obviously I'd rather have my
health that's why I'm asking a question
if if because and but that's why I said
you're loved and liked and admired it's
not it's it's very hard to have all
those three very very cuz you can't act
and have all those three the only way
you can have all those three is to be
all those three and you are all those
three so it's not a hey Christopher
what's the 17 steps to be loved like and
admired you can't do it it's genetics
part of it is your personality your DNA
that's it there's a part of it that
you're so but let's go back to that so
Michael wanted to be the goat mhm so
when he stepped away at three you know
and and we've all heard the stories you
know last dance was it his father did
David Stern say step away for a year and
a half then he comes back but he stepped
away from the game he want to go do
baseball because you know his original
love was baseball and then he comes back
and wins three more but Michael wanted
to be the goat like he wanted to be
magic had five I'm going to have six it
was one of those things right Brady
comes which we was with Brady what
couple months ago we had him at the
event and I said you know um
the seven was seven because you wanted
one more than belich or one more than
Michael because Michael's got six
championships and belich and him won six
together so did he want to win a seventh
to say I've done one more than two now
obviously publicly you may not reveal
the true internal motives and drives to
anybody else you're like yeah you know
no it wasn't the reason but you know
what you know I just kind of wanted to
test myself that's like the right answer
to give and then there's the answer of
no I wanted to give him the middle
finger and tell him I can win without
bill and I can win one more than Michael
and people got to stop saying that guy's
the Jordan of the industry no they got
to start saying that guy's the Brady of
the industry do you relate more to a
Michael and a Brady when you're by
yourself or do you relate more to a
Barry Sanders a Calvin Johnson some of
these guys that left the game I don't
know if you know who Calvin Johnson is
or who Barry Sanders is I know Barry not
Calvin Calvin Johnson Megatron 81 for
the the Lions right the guy was a and by
the way one of the greatest physiques in
the NFL ever both of these guys just put
NFL yeah uh Calvin Johnson was one of
the greatest receivers ever and they
retired early and they stepped away from
the game and whenever anybody would ask
the question say Barry why'd you leave
so early yeah I just left early yeah if
you would have kept you would have been
past EMT Smith everybody knew that
that's not what I'm doing the game for
so which of those two do you more relate
to the crazy guys like the Jordans and
the bradies or the guys that are doing
it because they like it and at one point
if they stepped away and they didn't
beat anybody else they're totally cool
with it it's funny because when I
started my career and I mean it's
impossible not to watch Michael Jordan
and just feel fire burning in your heart
everybody no matter who you are you feel
that he's like that's why he you say
you're the Jordan of your industry but
when I was younger he was a guy I looked
up to I read Relentless by Tim Grover
you know the Last Dance came out my
career a lot of these things going on I
was like like you know kill
everyone like the competition I
want to beat this guy hold gr like all
that stuff I felt that and I was like
hell yeah and then I started to kind of
like think about that and it didn't it
didn't line up with me I read it and it
lightened me but it didn't line up with
who I was and what I wanted to be I
wasn't the so much of I want to
sacrifice my whole life to do this it
was like no I actually realized that I
still get more joy from the
relationships with my parents and my
wife and I like being friends with
people and being friendly I'm light more
light-hearted than that I'm not the
aggressive guy's going to kill you I'm
just going to show up and do my best and
I'll try and bring everybody else around
me up too and I really realized that
through part of my career and that was
when I realized that it wasn't my goals
weren't external to be the best compared
to someone else it wasn't the best to be
in 20 years from now when someone else
was trying to win be like no you can't
beat me cuz I had eight and you can only
get five it was truly that does nothing
for you no okay I can't say nothing
Everyone likes that a little bit you
know I love the fact that I'm the champ
right now and what comes with that but
what drives me more truly being the best
man I can be and knowing that will lead
to me being the best father I can be and
that I've always been veral about that
the number one thing I've always wanted
to be in my life with a dad and if being
10 times Mr lumpia would take away from
me being dad 10 times Mr lumpia
that's not what I care about that's kind
what I fig that's kind of what I figured
with so so if that's the
case
um I'm gonna play the role of a manager
and agent here without I being one all
right and I don't benefit from you doing
anything okay I don't make money off you
I don't get anything from you but I like
you a lot right just like a from a fan
perspective just seeing a guy I'm like I
just like this guy you know how certain
people you're like you just want to see
that guy get whatever they want and you
root for them you give that Vibe okay
and if that's the case and you have your
uh uh baby that's due here soon in
2024 you're you don't relate to Michael
your February 2nd baby Michael of
February 17th both of you guys are
February babies I don't know if you know
this or not you guys are a couple weeks
apart so all right so no I don't that's
not me I read Relentless and part of me
goes I'm like no that's not really me if
I have to choose between winning 10 and
son the hell with it I would much rather
choose this so if that's the case and
there's no correlation between you
winning a sixth or seventh or an eighth
or ninth or 10th or any of that stuff
wouldn't it make more sense for you
today to step away from the game and
shock the hell out of the entire
industry at a young age and start a
supplement company which you already you
know of course that's already taking
place but take that to a whole different
level and encourage the youth hey yeah
you can have a good physique and all
this other stuff but there's more
important things in life than winning 10
more and forever you're going to be the
mythical figure that if that this guy
would have gone he could have
potentially won double digit because
what's the difference between five and
six or seven nothing mhm the only other
number that matters you know what's the
other number that matters it's nine yeah
so are you are you you want to go get
nine I don't really give a if I go
get nine yeah uh and then the question
that becomes do I risk going another
four and what if I want to have two kids
three kids four kids I don't know how
many kids you want you're young you can
have 10 kids if you want right so more
likely have 10 kids and 10 olympias yeah
you'd more rather you'd much rather have
10 kids than 10 m okay great dude me too
I'd much rather have 20 kids if I had on
my way I'd have you know as many kids as
possible but does that ever cross your
mind where you're like if there's no
difference between 5 six seven eight the
only thing that matters is nine and even
some of the people are they're going to
say well you've never won an open
anyways it's not like it's this you've
never won an open you know yeah if you
came up and you won an open then you
would shock the hell out of the industry
if you went that rout now you're really
talking if you do that cuz now you're
five-time and you're leveled up so now
you become a different story of you know
he's a middleweight champion and he
moved up to lightweight champion and
then he moved up to light heavyweight
champ you know you're kind of going
through that part you
know does that at all cross your
mind it's crossed my mind for years
honestly and stepping away because it's
either nine or no other number really
matters yeah and that's what I it's
truly it's been for myself for the last
couple of years and I know that and this
year in the midst of my prep I when I
was going through all that for a
moment I have a therapist and I remember
talking to her and she told me this
after I was like I don't know if I can
even get through this one like what like
I felt so shitty I was so down on myself
I was like I literally don't even know
if I can get through this one if this is
even worth it right now cuz I was just
in a low spot and she was like you know
what if you step away you know your
family your wife everyone close to you
will love you the same nothing will
change other than the amount of trophies
you have on your shelf and you've always
said that's not what you care about and
I really understood that and that
relieved a lot of pressure from myself
and then I was like I'm not going to
quit you know that's I'm still not going
to give up on myself right now it's not
going to be in this low moment that I
choose to quit I'm going to push through
this and as I did I was like the relief
of that pressure of knowing I don't need
to win for anything right now but I'm
choosing to purely for myself big
mindset huge difference you know and the
fact that I got through that and
discovered that on my own I was like
yeah I can keep going and I'm going
to kill this fifth Olympia and no one's
going to even talk about someone come a
second to me and that's what I did and
also what I learned this year was very
and my relationship has progressed so
much in this and I was talking to some
Navy Seals actually we had down DJ
Shipley and Cole flacker with that tbrs
group they were down we were talking
learning how to turn a dial back and
forth of when you're putting into 1%
being bodybuilder and they were talking
about going into perform as they do and
then coming back to their families how
hard that is and I don't want to compare
that to what they do cuz that's top
that's top performance but when me and
my wife learned this year was she
understood what I'm going through and
how important this is to me and she
understand that I am going to pull back
from our relationship for a little bit
and being the best relational husband I
can be in order to be the best Mr
Olympia I can be but she knows damn well
it's going to be worth it I'm going to
put everything in my when I'm off and
I'm away from from her I'm giving 110%
and when I'm done I'm coming back to her
and I learned how to kind of turn that
switch back into Mr Olympia mode and
back in a relational mode and that's I
think one of the most important things
to learn I imagine even you when you go
to business mode and you're like all
right we got to do this this data
projection this that and then you come
home and you got to be dad you know you
got to play with your kids that's a knob
you have to learn how to switch so
you're not bringing work home on to them
so this is something now that
bodybuilding has taught me on how to
turn that knob back and forth that will
make me a much better father and then if
I can manage that and balance things
going on in my life much better and it's
not taking away too much from everything
I have going on right now my kid will
still be a baby next year my wife still
understands what I'm going through she's
also a Miss Olympia from the past so she
gets it you know she knows what's up so
there's all these things that are going
through my mind and not only did I go
through a hard part beginning of my prep
but end on such a high but my
relationship was strong throughout it
you know and I don't want to talk to any
of these goats like MJ Brady any of
these guys a lot of them I believe
sacrificed a lot of their family time
and relationships to get there you know
so I don't want to do that and I don't
feel like I am right now I don't feel
like I'm pulling away from that for too
long or too much that it's actually
hurting it long term and chipping away
at it and I work very hard on that side
rather than just being a bodybuilder but
also being the best relational man that
I can be in other aspects of my life and
I know it's not hurting that right now
that's why I have these checks in place
where if I knew with my wife it was
literally hurting our relationship I
would leave I'd be done right now if I
my health was deing if decreasing if I
was doing my blood work and I was
getting sicker every year I'd be done
right now but I'm improving these things
these things are all getting stronger my
I'm happier than ever in my relationship
my business is getting better my health
is getting better everything's still
progressing and I'm still enjoying what
I do and I still have that fire to keep
pushing myself so I'm like why would I
stop right now you know are you are you
religious Chris you go to you go to
church or I'm not no I was raing Canada
and I'm sure if I was somewhere else you
know I might have been but so was can
Canada just overall just not a really
big where CHR where I'm from it's not
very religious Ottawa Ottawa yeah Ottawa
yeah a lot of Canadians believe in the
the the the the Church of uh Justin
Trudeau is what they believe in oh
really it's JT yeah the Church of not
latterday Saints it's day Justin TR I
don't know if he is part of that camp
but uh some of those guys uh some of
those guys are but but uh on this topic
just to because I I I want to get my
question answered or maybe you know know
where you're at um is there do you feel
like U so you're committed to doing your
six you're going to go back for your six
this year you I don't make that decision
and this is why I've said this every
year some people know I'm not
bullshitting I don't make that decision
until I'm ready to start ramping up
again you know I haven't been training
for a few weeks now and I'm just
enjoying the
fifth are you interested is there like a
next impossible thing for you to do you
know what I'm saying is there the next
thing where you kind of need the next
challenge you do do you think about that
or no it's just routine you know because
there's certain like my dad is an April
10 baby okay and the significance of it
is what you and I talk about off off
pre- podcast he's born April 10th and my
dad can do the same thing every day for
40 years he's excited that's my dad okay
it's not everybody great skill to have
great skill to have it's a scary skill
to have because the the enemy is
intimidated the fact that you're still
that excited my dad is that guy he'll
just keep doing it won't get bored he's
good to go nobody can slow him down he's
81 years old right now in and out of
hospital he still goes can't stop
him is there a next challenge where it's
like you know babe what I'm thinking
about what what if we decide to shock
the world this year and what's that how
what do you think about if we made a run
to go do XYZ does that thought at all
cross your mind to want to run in the
open or no that's not even a thought you
ever think about it's definitely crossed
my mind and I've I've joked about it and
people always ask me about it but I mean
to go back to when I started I almost
retired when I turned Pro because I
didn't want to be an open bodybuilder at
61 one I'd have to be 300 lb you're tall
you discovered that when you were trying
to compete too that's when I stepped
away by the way crazy it's it's tough so
then when classic VI the came out I was
like here's my chance to keep going
let's go all in on
this and when I talk about how my health
has been progressing it's because of all
the little things I've taken away from
and added and changed to focus on that
outside of just being huge and I think
to go in the open I would have to
mitigate those things that I've put in
for my health checks and I'm not willing
to risk that so if I ever competed it
would be a Sim look to these pictures
how we look now but maybe a little bit
Fuller less lean just so I was a little
bit heavier but I wouldn't want to push
myself to that and I also don't like the
idea of competing to not be as
competitive as possible so hard for me
to go in the open knowing I could be
doing more to be more competitive and
not doing it yeah so that's challenging
for me so it's it's on my mind it would
would be fun absolutely but it's not
really in the cards right now and and I
I figured that's kind of where you would
be at uh because when I sit there and I
think about it from the standpoint of
you know what what it would do to get a
six seven eth it's really the ninth that
would matter so which means you got to
take it one year at a time and you can't
let the media and whoever these annoying
people that ask the stupid questions the
tough questions I don't know any of
these guys but some people tend to ask
these crazy questions that get you
thinking you're like I don't want that
pressure I'm doing whatever I'm doing
talking to my family my wife my friends
my mentors my peers and that's the route
I'm going to take but I think I'm like
you know if if if if a if a Chris gave
the same thing he's giving right now to
Mr Olympia classic physique what if he
did that to his business at this time
how much can he scale that to because
you know you saw what Bill Phillips did
with muscle media sold it you know got
hundred million couple hundred million
dollar you saw what that was EAS back in
the days and how that supplement took
off and you're seeing right now drink
and all these things do you really need
Mr Olympia to get to 30 million
followers I mean you'll post something
on in Instagram you'll get a million
likes in a heartbeat it's not like you
getting a million likes it's not like oh
my God it's got a million likes to you
it's just like a regular Tuesday when
you post something you really your
audience is like fully behind you right
and how do you monetize that because all
that's going to do is that's just going
to make your your children wealthier
generationally make the Bumstead Legacy
bigger in the future and there's timing
in that um and there's a storytelling in
that that's the only reason I asked the
question to say what is the next uh
challenge if the challenge isn't to go
to the next level which I would not at
all recommend doing as a friend I would
say don't even I wouldn't waste my time
with that um then what is the next
challenge I don't think nine is the
challenge I think the challenge would be
there's a massive opportunity to change
the game today and to be able to
influence and change the game you have
to have loyalty in
audience um you you have to be liked
where you can persuade you have to be
transparent
vulnerable you know check check check
and you have to do it when you're peing
winning and you leave people behind
you're kind of like oh Michael why did
you step away after the six you could
have won a seven or it's like that
feeling that's why I as the question to
see what the next big challeng is for a
guy like you and obviously winning the
open is not on that list no yeah and I
mean there's definitely more I can put
into business and right now I have the
best Partners ever and the reason our
businesses are doing so hot right now or
because of my partners who can handle
the back end in business when I need to
step away from bodybuilding there's
definitely more we can tap into but when
I talk with my wife about like the next
step and what really drives me right now
I reflect back on the things that light
up my heart the most right now the
little things that come in it's it's the
inspiration it's the help I give like
the younger generation the kids I hear
the stories I get the letters I get all
this there's nothing I like it
brings tears to my eyes now when I like
read these things and I'm like there's
there there's something in that that is
my next challenge I know like like I'm
not religious based off of pure religion
but I am I have spiritual beliefs I
believe in higher power and I have like
beliefs in the world and there's
something in that realm that calls me
and I know that to give back you know
bodybuilding is a very selfish thing it
starts very selfish it's just I want to
be big and then it begins a bit more I
can I can bring up my family and my
friends and my community and then
there's some aspect that calls me to be
able to give back more cuz I've been
given so much I've been so blessed like
when I tell you I thought I was going to
be done bodybuilding when I got sick
everything else has just been bonus and
I'm so grateful for it and I and I just
want to be able to give back some of
those feelings that I've had to others
and the next challenge is going to be
figuring out how and then executing on
that well you're 28 bro you got plenty
of time you ain't 45 you an old
fart you know you're 28 you got lot you
got a lot of uh are you saying I'm an
old fart well you're now are 45 both of
us my back hurts this whole podcast my
back has been hurting I just want you to
I'm going thr that out this guy's 28
with I know he's ridiculous he realiz
like how weird that is like Michael won
his first how old was Michael when he 31
3 31 years I don't know how old he was
30 or 31 he won his first this is 28
it's on his fifth uh which is pretty
wild ahead so um so Chris so Pat I don't
know if you know Pat second but uh came
out choose your enemies wisely I
personally when I when I heard that when
I heard him writing it cuz since I've
been here a year and a half I've been
here and chose your enemies and I
thought that's a bad thing I'm like why
would you want enemies but then I
realized you know what I mean especially
like in my in our job entertaining enemy
people are going to think you're out
searching for these people but I realize
that you need these people to to help
motivate you I just literally just
finished listening to his book I can't
read because I have ADD and everything
but do you have any enemies do you have
anybody that like that drives you to
keep going that you have that like this
these people or these organizations in
your mind that that push you that drive
you competitive l in bodybuilding or in
general all around business compe
competing personal people that bullied
you like anything that makes you go I'm
G to I'm taking this to prove to
these people to prove to that person to
to push you not in any huge aspects no I
mean you know it's always fun to have a
rival and competitive aspects and when I
started and I was coming second two
years in a row it was Brion Ansley the
guy who beat me two years in a row and
we were the only true people I've ever
competed against that really that
rivalry where we were kind of like you
know smile and shake hands but I knew
he'd turn his back and he was like
that he took my Champion
that guy you know and I and and I
respected him for it you should think
that you should think me you know
you shouldn't like me cuz I'm coming to
steal your and then he he retired
last year and it was like it was the
coolest moment ever cuz it was literally
like you cut a cord between us he was
retired and he was done and we were just
like hugged him we were on stage
actually and he knew he I won and I gave
him a hug and I was like thank you man
like you really like you pushed me back
when I was second thank you for this
challenge in this rivalry cuz when you
compete there's there's few things more
fun than having a rival and kicking his
ass you know and he he lit that up in me
but since then honestly no one really
has that fire to come up and kill me and
like I'm super nice to everyone
backstage cuz I know I'm going to kick
their ass you know I'll shake their hand
guys come back and they ask me for
selfies back they're getting on the
stage with me and they're like hey can I
get a picture with you before we go on
there I'm like yeah sure man
like and then and I know damn well
they're not going to beat me you know if
you're beat me or not ask me for a
picture you don't you're going to
glare at me across the room not
going to talk to me that's the only way
you're going to beat me so none of these
guys are there yet which is fun but it's
I have no rivalries any anymore right
now this guy who comes second amazing
bodybuilder Brazil Brazil Ramone
absolutely amazing great guy he does
speak English how B are his forearms by
the way stupid is it as big as it looks
if we samide each other in a t-shirt
You' be like that guy's winning po
remote this guy's forearms is that's the
first thing that to me I'm like that
just doesn't how tall is this guy I
think he's five 11 okay so he's tall
he's pretty T dud yeah yeah that that
picture doesn't do justice though you
got to go a little closer when he's like
not posing to see what those no that
doesn't do just give me Chris he know
right there look at that yeah that shows
it yeah oh my God what his arms are huge
his forearms are the same size as his
biceps he's like 15 20 pounds lighter
than me I think on stage but his arms
are way bigger so but I see you when you
see him I still see the way you look at
him I see how you look at him you look
at him like you know you're not beating
me like you almost look at him like U
like nice nice to see you but no but I
see that the look is with the smile and
the
smirk uh like you see from pump and iron
where you know Arnold was toying with
Lou and saying Lou you're six months out
you know I mean you're good but if you
only had three or six more months you
may have had a chance and the dad
correct him he says no he needs three or
six months and he's haven't you've seen
that scene with oh with his mom with the
whole family yeah
he I see you I see you to see that's the
part where I think there like even right
now the psycho competitor came out for a
split second there's no way you're going
to win five without but there's a part
about competition also is to make your
opponent think you're not that
competitive right there's different
style of competition there side of
competition that's just like to to hide
which is how Doran Yates did it
everybody hated competing as Dorian
because everybody would compete in two
three four competitions throughout the
year yeah Dorian would only do one yeah
and they would be so pissed and he would
never party he would never go out and he
would go back to London UK wherever he
was at and this guy hung out with
gangsters I me UK's got some he's a yeah
and then he would come out they're like
freaking a this guy's back how the hell
am I going to be that was just stupid
but your style comes across as I'm just
a nice guy you know it's who I am and
then deep down inside you're like a
assassin but you hide it well yeah so
there's an assassin there that you you
do not reveal except when it comes time
to win and you give them that look to
say you're excited about being second
place cuz that's exactly where you're
going to be that's what you're fighting
for do you feel that way do you for sure
yeah you know and it's definitely an
aspect of my personality it's just like
the smile be friend with everyone but
like they don't have it you know and
they and they all I think they all they
seem to all know it because they're all
friendly and they all love me too you
know and they're all great guys it's
difficult when you have such great guys
you compete against but it it's it's
definitely fun and I do the same aspect
of Dorian you know I only compete once a
year and I'll talk to them second place
third place I'm friends with them Ron
and sis I'll go up to them I'll be like
I know you want to do the Arnold I know
you want to win the Arnold don't I'm
like if you want a chance to beat me you
need to take the next 12 months to beat
me but if you start doing the Arnold and
all this I'm like I'm recovering
for 3 months and then I'm training for
nine you are getting into another prep
and then recovering from that and then
doing like you're putting yourself
behind when I'm already ahead of you
you're telling them this told them that
yeah I have but they're like I want to
win the arold this much pay when you win
is it also 50ks or less I don't know
I've never done it I think it's 50 or
less but I'm not 100% what's your
relationship with Arnold what kind of a
relationship do you guys
have scarce yeah I've only spoken to him
maybe twice I think really yeah I've
never really spoken much to him is that
is that more from your end or his end I
think it's a bit of both okay I've never
attempted to communicate with him he's
never really tempted with me we met once
and he gave me congratulations shook my
hand said congrats and he just walked
away yeah congrats Chris he's I he's a
little checked out from the industry now
you know I think he's been kind of
verbal he's not a huge fan of the way
the open's gone and stuff he's more of a
fan of the super critical super critical
the open for the whole stomach the GH
what is doing to it which by the way I
love that criticism that he's given I I
love it that he's doing to yeah who who
did he not give Arnold to and then two
years later he said you got to fix the
belly and then he finally gave it to
many one I don't know who it was uh
there was somebody was there Ramy big
Ramy was it Ramy it could have been Remy
uh I don't know who it was if it was
Remy or if it was
um
um another another uh ponytail he's down
here in Florida got a great physique as
well fantastic physique dancer he was a
great poser oh Kai green Kai green yeah
so I don't know who it was but there was
somebody I remember like hey you got to
do something about the the stomach and
then they did and then he went and
picked it up and so so Arnold and you no
is there is there anything of
competitive between the two or not at
all being compared by the marketplace
hey who's got a better physique all that
stuff I I don't know I haven't talked to
him enough to really know I'm not sure I
don't like I'm not a I'm not a huge fan
personally because of I mean I was
always a fan of Arnold but the moment Co
and everything hit and he was making
those videos from home going you know
screw your freedom that dude that just
that one simple thing took me from
respecting him to where especially with
that accent telling people to hell with
your think which if you don't mind P I
wanted to ask uh Chris with we we
touched on Trudeau um I dude every
single Canadian I talk
to zero I have not heard one person be
like I really really like Trudeau from
they were complaining about you know the
increased homelessness the the poverty
the crime the way he he's basically a
dictator especially with Co what he did
with the truckers with the protesting um
and I know I'm pretty sure I want to
know your thoughts on him and where the
future of kada is going and also the
second question and I'm pretty sure is
always like criis and steroids and
needles did you did you have to take the
vaccine were you were you in Canada
where they were forcing
it um you know you talk about political
answers yeah I don't want to dive too
deep into that political side of things
yeah obviously and I don't think anyone
in the whole country including myself
the fan of the guy it's kind of hard and
what what and what do they like how long
till till is there a point where they're
going to be able to get rid of his ass
or he just seems like he's been there
forever I think it's similar to America
where you can only be reelected twice so
it's coming to an end soon and I
definitely I've increasingly saw a shift
of the whole country being like
this guy kind of you know and especially
after Co and I even saw a shift in the
morale of the country you know you you
go into stores after Co and it's
shifting back a little bit now but I
mean we were three years locked down in
Mass only allowed to go to grocery
stores people came out of that different
you know a large scale of people were
heavily depressed even if they weren't
feeling into more depressed than or know
they were they were definitely more
antisocial you go to a grocery store
people don't say hi to you don't look at
you anymore you know in Florida you walk
around people are just like oh my God
look at your musle up boy like people
are just like trying to make out with
you they don't give a damn you know in
Canada it's a lot more I saw that shift
of it being like and Canadians are
always known for being very politically
correct and nice and and I've heard
more people than ever being like
this guy I can't imagine it's not going
to shift another way and I I'm hoping we
can see a swing in the full realm of
North America back in the direction
where people people feel a little bit
more happy with the way the upper scales
going but just say yeah and you nailed
it just like the for and I get I I get
it I get what their entire plan was from
I mean from the Wuhan and the whole
whole situation but the thing that
you're were talking about people AR we
we have we're not going to recover the
children aren't going to recover from
that that little Gap in time that just
ruined them I was watching a video Pat I
know you would have been pissed off and
I'm pretty sure we've all seen it it's
of this little kid maybe three years old
2 years old and the teacher is forcing
this mask on the kid the kid is crying
hysterically and doesn't want they're
like no no no the damage has already
been done so like that when you when you
talk about that and I see that type of
guy 100% globalist ruining the country
and again not one person I've heard like
even if if you're here we see these
polls that come out yeah that's a this
is the video right here there this poor
kid is crying and the teacher is is this
in Canada I don't know where this was oh
I'm think but like the like look at what
we did to our kid children yeah it was a
little this poor kid are you saying this
because you're suggesting Mr Olympia
start forcing them to wear Mas that kind
of where you're going no but uh can you
stop this R but yeah it really pisses me
off but Chris so vaccine everybody in
Canada was basically forced to do it
yeah if you wanted to work or travel or
anything you had to yeah they were
checking at restaurants at and now with
the with all the heart diseases that are
happening myocarditis is on the rise uh
heart cardiac arrest there was a I saw
of a uh major or captain in the United
States Navy he pulled out the sheet 95%
of his Pilots are all having heart
problems right now and there's going to
be zero accountability for what they for
what they force on us politically this
there's this new guy in Canada who is
like the lot Pierre Marcel I believe I
don't know if you know who he is or not
who's going around Pier Olivera yeah
that's that's who it is Pier Olivera who
seems very very interesting and Justin
cannot stand this guy and that's a good
sign Pat no no this is a this is a
quality guy in Canada that a lot of
people are pretty excited about to see
what happen my experience with Canadians
has always been great these are the they
drink cocy they're fun they're good to
be around they're just chill you know
it's just in the last few years Justin
Justin made people look at Canadians in
a different way some Canadians like dude
I don't I'm not that guy I'm I'm just a
Canadian as I'm just a simple guy and I
don't know what he's done so cuz now
when you look at a Canadian you're like
man he must probably be like that guy as
well no a lot of them are leaving here
Florida's where it attracts a lot of can
Ians anyways but let's let's go back to
bodybuilding I want to wrap up with a
couple other thoughts here before we
finish up okay so uh relationship what's
your uh uh relationship with steroids
because for me when I was first wanting
to get into bodybuilding I was talking
to this guy in the gym who was taking
steroids and he says before you do
anything read the steroids Bible this is
30 years ago you know there's addition
one 2 3 4 five and all this stuff and
then there's a couple other uh uh books
that have been written about this back
then there was a video done with Mr
Olympia guys being interviewed with
their faces was blurry and they're all
answering as if you can't recognize
who's who you can you know want to St
blast that's Ronnie like you can
recognize the body more than their face
recognize all of it what are you guys
doing hiding yourself we know who you
are but it was a way of saying well you
know the truth about steroids and oh my
God yeah we don't use them and everybody
was uncomfortable talking about it right
now people are more open to say here's
what I've done here's what I've done
what does the average person not know
about steroids that they need to
know everything there's probably a lot
to it and I mean it's funny I was doing
a I did a Q&A in Dubai the other week
and some kid just literally probably 17
asked me if he should get on steroids
and I'm like no like first of all I
always tell people if you have to ask
someone else you shouldn't and the side
effects to it can vary so greatly
depending on the person you just never
know what you're going into you know you
could do one cycle and then your natural
testosterone could be dumped for the
rest of your life or you have to be on
trt forever it can make you infertile it
can lead to more risk of heart disease
you know increase of cholesterol it can
affect your liver your all your organs
it can be very damaging especially when
abused which is typically people can get
addicted not addicted like a drug but
you get addicted to the result and how
you feel how you look and all that stuff
so I definitely recommend anyone at a
young age don't even begin to touch it
if your physique is still progressing
don't even think about touching it and
if you're not thinking about doing this
by body building thing forever then
don't even think about touching it it's
cuz some people have an idea they want
to compete and they're like I'm going to
do my first cycle and compete and then
they compete and they hate bodybuilding
because it sucks it's a lot shittier
than you think it is when you get into
it especially at a high level and then
now you've done this potentially
long-term damage to your body just for a
12we prep to try and compete and you
can't go back on it it's just not worth
it so I just always tell kids I it's sad
it's even to kids but to wait as long as
possible to even think about it make
sure that your nutrition your recovery
your training is all perfect and it's
been perfect for years to the point
where you've hit your natural Plateau
where you can't really make progress
anymore and then entertain what is it
really worth it to you understand the
risk is the risk worth it to you is it
going to be a long-term thing or are you
building a career going to school and
this is just like a side Hobby and is
that really worth risking your health
you know how do you educate yourself
like if I want if I want to learn if I
want to learn more how do I start okay
because today if you're above 40 and you
go see a a um not a doctor there's some
of these guys that you go to and hey I
I'm a lifestyle doctor anytime you hear
words like this lifestyle you know we
can get you on trt peptides all this
other stuff let's see your blood levels
let's do your blood test oh okay your
testosterone level is only 320 you know
that's not good for your heart and
there's a book that came out called the
Ageless man that anybody under they
tested with rats and you know if you're
uh oh testosterone levels below this
it's actually got an increased chance of
a heart attack and all the stuff this
book that came out you know AIS land a
lot of people talk about this and then
they get you on trt right so you need to
get at this level if somebody wants to
learn more about steroids to go and
educate themselves how should they
start it's definitely challenging and I
think the world of trt is different than
steroids the way I look at it steroids
are a little more underground they're
higher doses more compounds more things
going on I think if you're over the age
of 35 and you have low te I think trt is
a great thing for you I think be able to
have that energy and be healthy and burn
body fat to have those capabilities is
healthier than taking a little bit of
trt so learning it it's hard you know
there's a bunch of people on the
internet now who talk a lot of
and a lot of people who are really good
so it's hard to differentiate that but
in any aspect you can get shitty
business advice you can get good
business advice you have to do a lot of
research and be smart enough to think
for yourself you have to have people you
trust who are maybe in the industry
maybe some doctors who are a little less
mainstream and more Progressive who can
actually communicate to you about it but
also once you hear something from them
research it you know learn how to
properly research get backed articles
multiple sources all this stuff it's
it's a difficult world out there out
there with so much information being
able to understand anything it all has a
risk of being yeah a lot of
doctors you talk to they don't even know
you go to doctor and say what do you
know about this I I I don't know it's
not good for you it's not this it's not
okay and then you know the the key then
becomes some people you go to they give
you too much of it they're like no
here's what you got it's not going to do
anything you're going to be all right so
it's important whose counsel you take
because there's the extremes on uh uh
both sides one that is zero tolerance at
all I don't want to know nothing about
it and there's another side that is
Extreme The Source becomes like who do I
trust to go talk to where I can get this
Intel from and is there a book or a
website or an article or somewhere to go
to where you like start here and then go
from there or no no really no really no
not that I would ever come across myself
not the fact that you would would ever
come across yourself how did you learn
about it like for for even you to be a
where you're are like who did you like
maybe not even a name but was it
yourself like hey everybody's talking
about this what is Anadrol 50 what is
DECA what are the compounds that do well
together is Winnie good for you what's
winra what's waterbased what's oil based
what's Oral what's this what's that like
how did you start learning about all
this stuff or was it the fact that maybe
you had somebody in your life that had
all the years of education where you had
an edge because somebody could tell you
don't waste your time with this do this
this is what this guy did that's what
these guys are using let's go research
let's start off with the
blood is that where kind of you have a
little bit of insight it was definitely
a bit of both of that you know and I've
I've always been a relationship person
and I'm building relationships is like
the biggest thing progressing in
anything having people you can trust so
I had people who could trust who were
helping me and they were always like
minimum effective dose always start with
the least possible and then go up from
there and then at a young age I had to
run in with my health issues and that's
when I was like okay okay like this
didn't cause it but it could make it
worse so you hear things like Tren and
Anadrol and all these things and these
are the hardcore ones all right
hardcoree usually means harder on your
body as well if it works more it's
probably harder on your body stay away
from those do the more this if you can
get prescribed from a doctor it's
probably more research and healthier
you're going to be doing higher doses
than a doctor would but minimum
effective dose start with as small as
possible and slowly increase you know
you don't need to throw the kitchen sink
at it to start you start small and
slowly progress over time and change
every other variable before that
variable you know if you can change I've
still been progressing my recovery my
nutrition my training everything has
been getting better over the years so
that I can change all those variables
and I haven't had to change the amount
of stas I take for the last 5 years it's
decreased over my career really no
I mean mus my muscle maturity too is a
real thing you know I've only been
training for I've been training for like
14 years but that's not that long in the
world of bodybuilding I'm only 28 and
I'm still my body's just staying the
same weight but I look more mature more
dense over time so I don't need to be
just like blasting to get huge I'm
fine-tuning everything else training
harder and I've been able to progress
with my work ethic you know and there's
a lot more to say about that than there
is just taking more drugs is there is
there any website AI that you know you
can look at someone's physique and you
put your physique there to say you can
actually have a physique that one day
you could compete for mro Olympia is
there anything like that that exists or
no I don't know you know why I asked
that question the reason why I asked
that question is because some people
think they can't and and you can do you
think you can generally tell with a kid
after he works out for about a year like
you have the right physique that if we
build it PR like you know the endomorph
the mesomorph the ectomorph all that
stuff to say you could actually do
something with this body here do you
know what I'm saying like you look at a
16y kid like this kid's got something
here with the body that it puts together
or you're like no I don't I disagree I
think you got to go five years to see if
somebody's got it I would say there's I
mean there's a scale to everything
there's the people with worst genetics
in the world where you could imagine if
they could train for a year and they
can't even lose body fat or it's very
hard to it's probably going to be
difficult for them or if they're 110
pounds and yeah but in the middle realm
where most people lie I would say it
takes years to really see if you can or
not because I've seen people who have
trained for a long time and look good
and I'm like you know they're okay and
then they start learning a little bit
different they find a new edge of how
hard they can train and all of a sudden
their physique changes in a year more
than it did the past three years so it's
everybody's so different I just say that
cuz you know when you see Arnold when he
was at 17 the way his chest would stay
up or you would look at uh uh you
younger like look at the way you me I
would I would say at a Mr Olympia level
yeah then you can probably tell when
they're young yeah if you don't have a
like that first picture of me with that
headband and that green shirt yeah yeah
that's the one I was in high school full
natural been training for a few years
you know I'd just been learning how to
eat I was just eating a lot I didn't
know properly how to and obviously I had
a hell of amount of muscle on me for a
high school student are there any
supplements for you where you like to
these are some of the go-to supplements
that I would you know spend some time
researching and looking up more because
back in the days you know it's it's very
trendy right oh creatin o hmbo v2go you
know clao all this stuff is there
anything where it's like these
supplements you know whether you want to
be a bodybuilder or not your body may
may need some of this this is what you
want to look up and then some of the
ones if you are a bodybuilder and you're
competing these are some of the go-to
supplements and maybe it's some of them
that you sell yourself yeah I mean I
always look at things that stand the
test of time creatine monohydrate is the
most basic cheapest thing you can buy
it's been researched the most and it's
been proven to work the most and it
absolutely does work it's not going to
be like steroids where you can to change
your life but it will help your recovery
and your progress and you will get
better from taking it and then based off
that it's just nailing nutrition in my
eyes you know pre-workout can help you
have a harder workout get more Vaso
dilation get a little more blood FL
flooding to the muscles but it's not
necessary it just helps protein powder I
think is a huge help because not if I'm
having to get over 200 grams of protein
in a day it's hard to get that from food
inexpensive a shake will help you get
there but other than that everything
else is just kind of bonuses that aren't
really needed and I've gone through
Olympia preps where all I've taken was
and protein and then everything
else was taking steroids of course but
it was focused more on diet nutrition
got it got it so and this is me owning a
supplement company being completely
honest nutrition and how you eat is the
most important thing and any I got this
article here about superfoods you know
sometimes super foods are like hey
here's a you know it's a very trendy
topic and uh uh so here we go superfoods
you should be eating according to a
dietitian US News and World Report
superfoods are nutrients rich foods that
can have positive effects on health due
to uh their high level of fiber vitamins
minerals antioxidants and you know Joe
bow a health and nutrition expert
defines superfoods as wholesome food
that inherently has components that can
improve health and those foods are
typically low and unhealthy ingredients
like salt sugar and saturated fat some
of the Super Foods does it have a sit
here with some of the super foods are
Rob or no uh uh diet rich in fruits are
there any Super Foods like hey liver you
know is there heart or is there any
superfood you you say these are some of
the things that I have in my diet or no
it's just Steak and Fish and Chicken
it's pretty simple it's all healthy
stuff I think you know fruits veget I
think Whole Foods eating as much variety
of Whole Foods is the best thing that
you can do single ingredient Foods is if
anybody changed their entire diet to
single ingredient Foods you'd be
healthier the less processed you
eat the better and you talk about like
lower testosterone and stuff going on
right now I think a lot of that is from
processed foods you know having shitty
crops so a lot of the natural foods are
even shitty over here microplastics and
everything all that stuff I think that's
really leading to low testosterone in
men and they've proven some of it has
happen it's kind of like underage
studies that people don't look at too
much but I think a lot of that comes
from diet and lifestyle and it's hard in
America and every everybody said that
and I experienced it for the first time
myself this year you go to Italy for 10
days and you eat whatever the you
want you'll lose weight you'll feel
great you'll have great energy look
amazing I literally was like getting
leaner eating past and pizza all day I
was like what the and then I came
back from Italy I was like all right I'm
going to get back on diet and started
eating on diet and it felt like a little
more inflamed it didn't feel as good I
was like there and how many fat Italians
do you see honestly you go to Europe
when you go to Europe how many fat it
you don't see a lot of fat they're
walking everywhere we're ubering the
lifestyle the walking the food yeah
but part of it is the processed food I
mean there's this article here about
eight major factors that cause low
testosterone levels yeah one aging okay
which makes sense testosterone naturally
declines with age starting in the 40s
and significantly dropping at around 50
about 20% of men over 60 have levels
that would qualify as low excess weight
obesity is linked to low testosterone
levels due to factors like leptin
inhibiting production low testosterone
can lead to reduced physical activity
and weight gain creating a vicious cycle
okay three testicular problems
conditions affecting the testicles like
undescended testicles or uh cl cl felter
syndrome what the hell is that Rob can
you pull that up to see what that is
don't Google image that one though yeah
don't do
it uh is where boys and men are born
with an extra X chromosomes package of
genes found in every cell in the body
there are two types of chromosomes
called the sex chromosome and determine
the genetic sex of a baby okay um four
pituitary disorders issues with
pituitary gland or can uh lower hormone
levels potentially due to conditions
like the Calin syndrome chronic health
conditions lack of sleep diet uh certain
drugs and medication chemotherapy
substant abuse and Other Drugs can
disrupt testosterone production uh uh
what are other things that people do
that lower testosterone levels and what
can they do naturally to increase their
testosterone levels I mean a lot of the
stuff that I hear is kind of taboo kind
of not proven yet but I really do think
that processed food in general does that
I think the the pesticides we spray on
our crops is kind of infecting a lot of
our food that's really impossible to
avoid I think microplastics and water
and in our food and all of the way
everything is just helped can affect
that as well and I think going back to
the way we used to do things in the past
the best way to do it I think obesity
has led from like you said less walking
people are just way less active now I
think it's just depression as well can
be it I think that's a conversation that
is endless but having a community in the
past like a community that you spoke
with and helped and gave back to walked
around with saw and spoke to every day
rather than driving places being on your
phone and not talking to anyone just
affects your mood overall and you know
my my wife is huge on a lot of these
natural things so we really try and only
drink water out of uh glass bottles
probably wouldn't let me drink this but
like we have drink she would but she
tries we try as best as we can to avoid
plastic you know like glass Tupperware
we have a big five gallon Mountain
Valley thing that's all glass as well
just avoiding as best as possible and
some people say this is like crazy spear
like no this is great this iszy stuff
but I I mean when you think about it
logically it makes a lot of sense and
there have been a lot of studies on it
that people can look into themselves
that haven't maybe gotten attention they
need to but they're probably a lot of
people who don't want anyone to have the
attention on these things so so it's
hard to say and I think going back to
the way naturally things it can be
pushing your body and training to
different levels I believe will help
testosterone increase whether it just be
walking more if you were very stagnant
having a little bit of walking training
you know pushing High Progressive
overload and training weights naturally
will can help bring up your testosterone
a little bit the healthier you are the
more sleep you get sleep is huge
especially in growing teenagers if
you're like on your phone all night
getting shitty sleep eating processed
foods being stagnant I believe it will
result in less testosterone as you age
whereas if you're getting eight plus
hours of sleep and eating healthy and
training hard it's going to help you a
lot more Chris not to cut you off go P
can you P are you staying on the top
yeah I was just going to say about
because you know I know you've been
following like Bill Gates has been
buying up all this Farmland they're
anti-meat they're trying to push for a
meatless Society they're trying to tell
us to eat bugs which is another
testosterone killing uh thing I don't
know if you if you've heard about it
Kristen do you think that that that's a
concerted effort to make men cuz we're
talking about men and to
to make us weaker have you been hearing
anything about about this guy and how
there he's going towards zero meat like
you have to eat protein mhm i' I've
definitely heard about it I think all
these diets that come in are kind of
and maybe that's why the whole
vegan thing is pushing so hard some
people absolutely maybe you feel better
eating less meat majority of people I
don't think do you know I think any of
these fat diets are if you feel
better eating something you feel better
eating something it's very dependent on
the individual you know and I think it
some of it goes back to our lineage
depending on where your history comes
from maybe you're better on a
Mediterranean diet eating more fish and
stuff like that pescatarian diets I
think are very healthy but it's just at
the end of the day what they are they're
eliminating all these diets are
eliminating more stuff if you're vegan
you're eating a lot less other if
you're pescatarian you're eating a lot
less stuff if you're carnivore you're
eating way less stuff so of course
you're going to lose weight and feel
better for a period of time but you can
also just eat less
crap you know can go to the testosterone
levels of people worldwide on what
countries have the lowest and the
highest have you seen this chart before
I haven't seen it's really interesting
Rob just showed this to me yesterday the
the M right there take a look at that
zoom in a little bit so from 198 this is
from what data from
62 to 84 where are can you go to the
other page you had with the numbers on
the same slide if you go all the way up
I think they actually had the numbers of
people uh no you showed us a number
where what was actually yeah there you
go they right there testosterone level
in us from 1960 to today okay zoom out a
little bit because there's some other
thing that shows what those colors are
yeah testosterone decline okay so look
at 1960s the average testosterone level
for male was around 650 okay then we
stayed at 650 till around 1980s and then
there was a sudden decline to 500 in
1995 and then we dropped to 400 450 in
2012 and now we're getting ready to go
below 400 you know and and if you go to
through countries go below to show the
map that you had yeah keep going so this
is in the States on who has the highest
testosterone level it's interesting you
see who has the highest who's got the
lowest
um where is the lowest rout so this is
after 2007 West Coast testosterone level
dropped South Florida's kept it
Virginia's kept it so ladies Virginia
testosterone levels was very high um
Beverly Hills was the lowest what did
you see that Beverly Hill Beverly Hills
was one of the lowest okay keep going
lower this is a very interesting data
they're shown on testosterone levels
World regions now go lower this is the
one that shows this showing America
being high America was shown High then
it got lower oh current current current
got lower to between 450 to 499 that's
but we used to be 6 700 years ago you
know how is this you know I don't know
how much studying you've done with this
testosterone level drop in is this also
going back to what's changed lifestyle
food a lot of that stuff that you're
kind of going back to yeah I mean I I
haven't researched it obviously I'm not
a a medical student of this aspect in
this but I think there's a lot of
evidence that would say that and I've
seen firsthand a lot of people who have
who are eating unhealthy and living
stressful Lives who have low
testosterone and they'll like talk to me
be like should I hop on trt or something
something and I'm like first of all not
going to tell you this advice I'm not
your doctor but try this you know try
sleeping more remove some stress create
a proper routine you know like sleep
better eat better cut this processed
food out of your diet and they have seen
a natural increase coming up nothing
like from 200 to a th000 but it starts
to it starts to raise and if you start
that at a young age I'm sure it will
develop more effectively you know
there's stuff you can if you're 0 to 18
living a very unhealthy lifestyle that's
kind of what sets your whole body up for
the future for your entire life so if
you're able to do it from a young age
you're going to be a lot better off
here's another one for you obesity 42%
Americans are living with obesity okay
uh axio more than 4 in 10 us adults are
obese that's insane when you think about
a number like that by the way with
states in the South and Midwest showing
some of the highest prevalence a new
analysis that came in from uh norc at
the University of Chicago shows obesity
is associated with hypertension
cardiovascular disease stroke and other
conditions that are among the leading
causes of preventable M premature death
but strategies of treating obesity are
changing with doctors prescribing a new
case of drugs in record numbers despite
questions about their long-term effects
and Hefty price tag West Virginia and
Mississippi have highest obesity rates
at 51% damn the District of Columbia had
the lowest obesity rate DC 33% followed
by Colorado at 34% obesity
disproportionately impacts Black and
Hispanic Americans uh analysis shows and
then obesity rates amongst children is
also higher
more than 177% of children 0 to 17 are
considered obese um and if you go even
deeper in that Medicaid covered children
have a considerably higher obesity rate
at 26% Medicaid cover children compared
to 11.4% among children with private
insurance Alone um and it's even at a
point right now where Oprah Winfrey what
was the story that came out about Oprah
Winfrey with this new draug called the o
oen they they they didn't say the actual
name but she's she say shaming me well
no she's like well stop shaming her that
she's taking it like now because she
dude she's 69 years old she went from
Oprah can you show the picture of what
Oprah look like she look like let me
explain something to you guys if I was
drunk and it was like a and I saw Oprah
out I would go for it you would consider
it 100% because it's Oprah or it's Oprah
very good question te yeah techical but
like look at dude are you kidding me and
she's 70 in in in on the how old is she
right now 69 years old so she dropped 40
lbs apparently using this drug called
OIC and to the point where Chelsey
Handler said said that she took it as
well saying her anti-aging doctor
prescribed it to her unknowingly however
she stopped using a stating I'm an
irresponsible drug user but I'm not
going to take diabetic drug Tracy Morgan
said that he's been taking it as says I
went and got a prescription and I got
OIC and I ain't letting it go Megan
McCain is refusing to take it kid she
says it's horrifying unfair and
disturbing don't rush me but Rob you had
you had a stat 1500% what Rob didn't you
have a what was it a poison Center see
nearly
1500% not 150 1,500% increase in calls
related to injected weight loss drugs as
people accidentally overdose that's not
good maybe here's a question for you
what's more dangerous for your body
taking steroids to develop more muscles
and increasing your testosterone or
taking drugs like this OIC that all of a
sudden you're going to drop 40 pounds in
a month what's more dangerous for your
body you think I mean there's no black
or white answer to that you know if
you're abusing steroids it could be
worse if you're abusing OIC you abuse
anything it could be worse I don't like
the idea of taking drugs like for weight
loss obviously especially when it's
something you can achieve without it and
I do I have seen plenty of people who
have used this and they've used it
they've lost a lot of weight and then
they try and come off and their appetite
go through the roof they put all their
weight
because it supresses your appetite makes
it hard for you to eat it makes you
almost a little nauseous so it's hard to
eat and then it regulates your blood
sugar so your bodys it's getting enough
nutrients in but it often isn't so
people can be malnourished undereating
having no appetite taking this lose
weight feel great and then when they
stop that appetite comes back with a
vengeance and then they eat again and
lose it and they're like I need to
get back on that drug oh God if that's
not an addiction I don't know what is
you know and then now they're addicted
to this drug that was just discovered
one year ago of course testosterone has
risk and it's D how long has been
probably probably a little over one year
but it's new it's very new there
definitely aren't 15 plus years of
clinical trials on this on humans yeah
and diabetic drug everybody out there
all these people right now taking it are
the clinical trial what side effects are
going to be in the next 10 to 15 years y
it's like it's just like the vaccine we
don't know has hasn't had the the
science hasn't hit yet and like steroid
a lot of people take it without knowing
the risk and I think that is dangerous
and I don't want to compare them say
one's better than the other because I
don't think you should take any jug
without understanding the risk but I
don't think these people understand the
risk I bet you they go in and they say
you know hey take this there's no side
effects that we've found yet and people
are like okay they don't care bro if if
you're going to fix one thing they don't
give a about the aftermath As Long
As theyd lose the weight and it's c yeah
dude I have a cousin my cousin is is on
this and youe drastically lost weight
and how many of these people do you
think are getting paid how many of these
celebrities getting paid to talk about
taking this of course that's a that's a
plug an Oprah plug of but I don't think
she mentioned it Chris but I'm pretty
I'm pretty sure bro that like everybody
knows what there there's no secret like
new drug out it's OIC everybody's taking
it but OIC and wigi brought in
$4.8 billion of sales you ready in the
third quarter in the third quarter what
can you pull pull this up Rob in the
third quarter check this out I just saw
this on Forbes I'm going to send it to
you click on this link the article uh oh
that's one right there stay under so OIC
and wovi brought in $4.8 billion of
sales during the third quart order and
the drugs account for 52% of Novo
nordisk's $23.6 billion of total
revenue through 2023 is first nine
months up from a 36% share during the
same period whoa wow click on that
article click on the article to see if
there's any other data behind this 4.8
billion and a quarter zoom in so if this
is this is 4.8 billion it's more than
just Oprah Winfrey taking it just so you
know that there's a lot of uh uh 75%
last 12
months was EMP c caus Rec capitalization
to balloon from $230 billion last
October to $430 billion today remarkably
the firm's market value is now larger
than its home country of Denmark entire
annual economic output the company is
now worth
$430
billion wovi is approved in the United
States for weight management while OIC
is formally approved for the type 2
diabetes but it is often prescribed off
label for weight loss Goa lore didn't
Nick get banned in the UK or something
too you know what Nick can you I think
so zoom in a little bit more to see what
it says on that 100 stocks Bank of
America analysis projects American calor
consumption to dwindle as much as 3% by
2030 due to the rise of weight loss
drugs and package food and meat stocks
are Adit uh their worst loss streak
since the turn of Millennium so that so
that's what you were saying it's making
you not want to eat cuz it's thinking
making you think you're full uh search
what countries OIC is banned in what
country's OIC is Bann in that's crazy
that one product bet is worth more than
the country's economic that's insane oh
my God countries that have imposed such
bans Austria Austria France Greece and
Czech Republic Portugal pania Belgium
Slovakia and Spain in export though the
drug saying to export because of
shortages place that likely make it
imposs possible to export the drug so
it's not necessarily no it's not banned
but the first ones are bans the second
ones oh impossible to export so Austria
France Greece and Czech is a ban um very
interesting very interesting on uh how
it's going to affect 3% of the intake in
food by 2030 oh my God and there they're
seen a streak in the amount of uh food
we're taking months in a row
uh again I mean this this is a a person
like Oprah celebrities are taking like
dud look how great this person looks and
you get on and all of a sudden you're
hitting uh um all these effects to it um
interesting yeah OIC is a topic
something you're hearing a lot about in
the last 12 months I would say not
something you've heard about before it's
more recent blew up yeah yeah remember
that one drink you would drink and
within 24 hours you could lose 15 PBS uh
this is like 20 years ago did you know
about this you'd lose 10 to 15 lbs with
you go to the bathroom a lot no so you
would but you would go to a party
Hollywood was using this and it was
super popular so let's just see you have
you just have 12 hours boom you drink it
10 15 PBS you would be ripped but ripped
and it was like the next day for
sure but the party you look great worth
it aside from you feeling like but
let me see what else I got here boom
okay final thoughts here uh uh
Christopher before we wrap up um
um what what final thoughts do you have
to the audience people who are in your
world to follow you and those maybe that
haven't followed you and now because on
pbd podcast we've not had you know
bodybuilding we've had it on vment but
not on pbd podcast on vment the audience
would recognize it more what final
thoughts do you have for somebody that
is in the health business is in a
bodybuilding they want to get into you
know a a POS possibly bodybuilding what
message do you have to those who are
specifically in the health industry with
aspirations of wanting to get to the
next
level in the next level of Fitness
wanted to see if I can really compete
and maybe um do more with bodybuilding
what would you say to those guys I mean
as is being successful in anything it's
about mitigating where you put your
attention in time and effort you know if
you're wanting to take something to the
next level you have to start pulling
away from where you're putting energy
anywhere else and putting it into where
you want to be successful and every time
you do a little bit more in there you'll
become a little bit more successful so
you start to do that over time and if
you don't want to fully commit just do a
little bit if you're want to get in the
bodybuilding pull away from your social
life pull away from it and go into that
but also ask yourself where do you want
to be in 10 years is what you're putting
your energy into getting you to where
you want to be in 10 years or is it just
resulting you to be happy right now in
this moment and in 10 years you're going
to be like am I grateful and better at
partying or what I rather pulled away
from that and put a little bit more
discipline into bodybuilding and see how
where I could have taken that and the
beautiful thing about Fitness now is you
don't even need to compete really to
build something from it with social
media and the amount of people with
obesity problems right now all you have
to do is learn how the Body Works
improve your own self and then start
helping others and you can build a
business or help others off that so
there's a lot of avenues that can take
it but I think you
know something I take away from seeing
this is people are looking for the easy
way out do I think that's going to last
longterm in life no so what can you do
to get ahead of those people take the
hard way start working on yourself put
energy into the hard stuff be consistent
be disciplined and you're going to be
ahead of most of the population right
now you know if people are looking for
an easy wayo all you got to do is take
the hard way and be resilient and you're
ahead of most of the population or if
you're a really lazy guy just and you
don't want to work out and stuff and
you're lazy as just identify as
trans compete against women and beat the
out of them that's what else I mean
that's what they're doing they're just
lazy as hell are so fun that's what I'm
saying Chris male but there's not been
yet a male bodybuilder competing in
female oh there was actually somebody
that did it but not at the M Olympia
none of that has happened yet I hope
they would they turn him away if he I
don't think Jake would would I got
qualify yeah well I guess you're saying
that what I'm saying is what if a guy
slaps on some boobs and goes in compes
with the women they're not going to say
no I I actually don't think Mr Olympia
brand would do that today I don't think
if they did I don't I don't think they
know who Their audience is and I think
they know who Their audience is and
that's not their Audience by the way
final thoughts this drink this is your
bum energy can I have one yeah of course
crack us about this yeah I mean everyone
at my office was drinking like three
energy drinks a day at and now they were
all like 200 300 milligrams of caffeine
and they're all stemmed out and feeling
sick after it and I was like let me make
some a little bit lighter you know and
I'm being healthy I tried to be less
caffeine no food D nothing like that so
it's got 112 milligrams of caffeine some
cognizant in it for a neutral help you
kind of focus without being too jittery
simple little can you can drink a few of
them a day and still feel good and
what's your favorite flavor what's your
favorite flavor um Cherry Frost or peach
mango the peach mango is not fully out
yet but this one is Cherry Frost is out
so they can order the Cherry Cher Frost
is out you're seeing it on the on the
screen uh put the link Rob in the chat
in the description if you're a fan I
like it you follow him support the man
go place an order with bum sugarfree
energy drink Cherry Frost Christopher
it's been a bless having you on you the
man really enjoyed it looking forward to
doing it again in the future if you
decide to go for your six maybe we'll do
one right afterwards as well and looking
forward to seeing next year when you
finally reveal when your wife says now
we can tell the world I'm excited about
that moment to see what your reaction is
going to be thank you take care
everybody have a great weekend bye-bye
bye-bye